frankie montage will try to build upon
his last start when he was great against
the astros this past saturday allowing
six hits in just one run in six innings
they'll shift three to the right side on
jamer candelario
sitting 320 in his early at bats this is
game number 14 for both teams
and here's the delivery and that's a
check swing and did he go in the appeal
and yes on the appeal to third they ring
him up and that's a strikeout of
candelario
so the tigers fail to score with the a's
coming up in the bottom half and the
long time miami marlin right-hander jose
arena will be pitching for the tigers
so here's jedi's bounding 348 the 01
right into the shift and really castro
was there to grab hold of it
nunez
fly ball to shallow ride his first time
he's one for five in the series
no shift on here for nunez as the pant
legs pulled up
deep in the box from the right side with
a wide stance
and the pitch swing and a miss slider
down and away and
that's five k's for montas
matching zeroes with urania
mitch was right on a pitch he tattooed
it to right
didn't have enough
[Music]
carrie to get over the head of badou
to him on a line in right field
hayes are looking for the
power source to get plugged in here with
moreland 10 home runs 29 rbis last year
between boston and san diego
here's the 1-0 swung on slap and through
the right side past the shift by willie
castro it scores one with l'oreal around
third base and holding there is chapman
an rbi single for mitch moreland and the
a strike first they lead one to nothing
twice tonight mitch has hit the ball
well against irania this time he picks
up an rbi
got a sinker just above the knees 95 and
hit it so hard that the shift couldn't
stop it
runners at first and third and here
comes shawn murphy
murph struck out his first time up
slightly close stance from the right
side he swings and grounds with truck
into third pass the diving candelario
down the line and toward the left field
corner into scores chapman over to third
base is moreland into second with an rbi
double as sean murphy and the asep
double their lead to two nothing murph
sneaks one just inside the bag his third
double at his fourth run batted in
here comes elvis
see if he has some two out magic in his
bad with the bases loaded
the way montage is pitching tonight you
know they have a dynamite bullpen to go
with it
yeah this
this is
the point where you have to cut it off
at two runs montas looks too strong
have to attack this guy elvis andrews
six for 46. line drive to center field
long run for reyes and he makes a fine
running backhand to grab into left
center alvas andrews jumped on the first
pitch and squared it up
as the last three a's who put it in play
did this time it's an out two runs for
the a's we head to the fifth
so here's
akil badu coming up
three-two pitch again to badu swung onto
miss throws at five a fastball 95 and
montas right now is offering a gem and
halfway through our ball game tonight
after four and a half these lead the
tigers three nothing
two outs and that leaves it up to matt
olsen
olsen sharp line drive single down the
left field line first time up and then a
soft little dribbler with the tigers
infield shifted and
candelario tried to make the play on the
infield grass but couldn't and that was
big because it
ended up
ending could have been over the next
batter but instead
that little infield single helped extend
the inning from moreland to drive in the
first run
tigers shift three to the right
the one two fastball strike three called
another generous call off the plate
inside
olson doesn't like the call a break for
uranium strands are under at second base
we played five in oakland so here's
willy castro's walk and strike you out
now here's the pitch it's on the way and
that's taken ring him up high fastball
perfect pitch
96
castro is down seventh strikeout for
montas
two out here's renato nunez
of course a ton of power renato
applied to right and struck out
as two runs five hits no errors the
tigers no runs
two hits and no errors frankie deals
it's a ground ball to short two steps
this right elvis has it goes to second
for the force in time
two hits and no runs allowed by frankie
montage through six we go to the bottom
half and it's still a two-nothing a's
so here's murphy who's struck out and
doubled had the rbi with his two base
hit down the left field line in the
fourth
and the one two
on the outside corner to get him
strikeout number six
for urania four uncalled third strikes i
can hear that a's the bench right now
man they got to be all over
hernandez the umpire credits ramos
for the receiving of that pitch
and now marcano will stand in
market went hard as last time up after
taking strike three in the first and
again in the third much to his dismay
from angel hernandez
there it is he strikes out kenna for the
third time tonight
all of them staring at the third strike
ramon has bounced to the third walked
and scored and fly to right
the one-two swinging a miss slider got a
middle of the plate
it just had good down to it if that's
the end of the night man
for jose iranian that's a heck of a good
start through seven innings
just gives up the two runs in the fourth
and he finishes strong eighth strikeout
of the night
ends the seventh made some adjustments
we head to the eighth inning it's still
two-nothing oakland
matt chapman tonight
he's reached base
twice
center field that's hit pretty well
reyes going back near the wall and that
baby's gone
and these get a cushion in the bottom of
the eighth and they take a three-nothing
lead
that got out just like that
his third home run of the year
straight away center field eluding the
desperation try at the wall by the
tigers center fielder victor reyes
so here's candelario switch it or
batting left three nothing a's
and from the stretch and here's the
pitch now and that swung on and popped
up on the infield near the pitchers now
lou is calling for giving way and the
first baseman olson makes the catch on
the back slope of the mound in that six
consecutive wins for the a's they blank
the tigers three nothing and after the
tough start to the 2021 campaign
on the 16th of april these have climbed
to the 500 mark at 7 and 7.